دكتور حاتم 60 طبيبا بيطري مصري معروف
بعاشق الخيل او طبيب الرحمه يعالج وينقذ
الخيول بلا مقابل مادي يملك دكتور حاتم
نحو سته ملايين متابعه راح حساباتي عرفي
فيسبوك انستغرام تيك توك ينشر فيه على
مقاطع للخيول التي يشرف على علاجها
واستعرض حياه الحيوانات المهمله قبل وبعد
انقاذها ساعد الاف الخيول ويقول انه انتج
دواء محليا لعلاجها دكتور حاتم هو طبيب
بيطري دوليا معتمد من الاتحاد الدولي
للفروسيه وكان حلقه الوصل بين الاتحاد
المصري والدولي للفروسيه وزاره الزراعه
كما كان له اول برنامج تلفزيوني متخصص
للخيول في الشرق الاوسط وحققت حلقاته اكثر
من 100 مليون مشاهده
دكتور حاتم احكي لنا بقى قصه شغفك
بالخيول بدا ازاي
كانت بالنسبه لي عارفه كل طفل بيبقى عنده
حلو كل طفل بيتخيل البطل بتاعه
حاجه معينه انا كان بطل بتاع الحصان
[موسيقى]
ولكن الحمد لله
وطبعا دخلت كليه طب البيطري
وبعد ما دخلت كليه طب كان المفهوم ساعتها
ان الطب البيطري ده يعني يعني كانت في
الوقت ده ما كانش احسن حاجه ان انت تدخلها
دكتور بهائم وانت والتريقه والكلام ده كان
كان يعني ما كانش عندنا ثقافه
احترام طبيب طبيب الحيوانات بالشكل اللي
موجود عليه حاليا الحمد لله
فدخلت بس يا حبيبتي ثانيه يا حبيبتي
يعني مش قادر اوضحها لحضرتك بس يا حبيبتي
بس خلاص خلاص
هي الخيل لها لغه الحقيقه مش هيفهمها غير
اللي بيعيش في الخير كثير اللي بقيت عايش
معهم بيتكلم نفس اللغه بتاعتهم انا بقى
بيني وبينهم بحس ان انا جزء من القطيع
يعني فهمم احس ان انا والخيل على طول
بيننا لغه اتصال جامده جدا ممكن تقول جزء
ممكن تقولي جزء منها موهبه ولكن الاكثر هو
تعايش
بقى طبيب الرحمه حضرتك بتعمل ايه بالضبط
انا طبعا الحمد لله وصلت في ال- اا في
الطب عامه طب الخيول يعني للطوب ليفل
كبروفيشنال ليفيل الجزء الاحترافي
حكمت بطولات محليه عالميه كض- بيطري ااا
كنت مسؤوله عن خيل من اغلى الخيول اللي
موجوده الحمد لله في مصر والعالم العربي
وبعدين
صعب علي قوي فكره الخيل لما بتترمي في
الشارع الكارو والتعذيب والكلام ده
بينهاكوها من التعب طبعا يعني لم يصرفه
عليها تغيير زيت ولا ولا عربيات ولا
الكلام ده خالص مش محتاجين فبياخذوا
الحصان يهلكوه تعب وما ياكلوش شايفه
بيتامن مع كلام ايه وما بياكلهوش ما
بيعملوش اي حاجه خالص وبيقوم راميين وبعد
كده في الزباله اول ما يستهلك او يحصل له
اي نوع من انواع الاصابات
او يحصل له اي نوع من انواع الاصابات
والحصان الحقيقه والله بجيب بعض الخيول
الجلد بتاعها بيكون بيطلع كده زي الورقه
فازاي في بلد فيها بني ادمين العاديات
الخيل اللي ربنا كرمها اكرم مخلوقات بين
الحيوانات ااا يعني مكرمه في جميع الاديان
والرسول وصى عليها والقران وصى عليها
فازاي ان هي يحصل فيها كده ان يموت من
الجوع والعطش تحت اشعه الشمس
[موسيقى]